impartial cherche depuis des heures la
landaise de lâche pas
pourquoi
c'est pas fini projet 3
je revis des jeux mythiques vraiment
dans ce koh lanta il est de plus en plus
c'est pour moi en fait koh lanta c'est
vous c'est l'eau le voile au long de cet
argent
tous les matins je vais faire du pied
quelque part
[Applaudissements]
regardez regardez ce que m'a rappelé mon
bon alors c'est l'arc là quand tu tires
et que tu doit éliminer quelques voix
s'élèvent quant à eux comment comment ça
s'est passé en fait jacques labat arrive
à faire passer ça la douane
parce que c'est compliqué de le mettre
dans son slip non mais tu n'es pas sa
place il pare soleil était parti avec
moi mais comment tu l'as mis dans sa
poche comme avant je devais dans la
valise s'est passé tranquille ça c'est
vrai ça c'est la sas et leur analyse est
certes que tu la bri sa cellule oui sauf
que j'ai pris at appris l'arrêt savent
pas et savent pas d'accord ça ce soir et
cette fois il a un amour parce qu'on a
vu le taux de péter walton mm là on à
l'arc
la semaine prochaine la magel et nous
amène le poteau la rue de vous non mais
franchement eversim tout un amour je
sais pas quoi tu m'en [ __ ] c'est un
cadeau des comptes en continuant encore
des preuves soit isabelle adéquate et
contrebasse et paribas c'est un peu
notre arc sa maman sakon web patron peut
avoir des preuves pour entrer avec l une
avec la machette s'il n'a pas désempli
taux d'intérêt la ville en lever sa
veste
c'est vrai ça il faut qu'ils partent sur
le bol d'or lui tout de suite un merci
s'accordent en tout cas un amour d'être
là môme aussi on est très heureux de
vous avoir pour les débris de koh lanta
est prévu le collier batterie ça a
commencé comme ça sur bath anthume a
même écrit peint vendredi soir eh ouais
après cette découverte les tice et
vincent décide donc de cacher ce collier
aux autres l'aventurier un rôle que le
chouchou des téléspectateurs pas prendre
très à coeur on adore vincent à
l'étudiant regardez c'est digne
d'hollywood mais pas le cinéma
ma stratégie c'est de chercher chercher
je suis arrivé sur le grand larousse et
je vais tout mettre en plein vote le
nouveau franchement baissier [ __ ]
c'est [ __ ] de mines home réduire ne
savait pas qui est rarement été aussi un
liste iv
je cours je joue bien je joue trop bien
on est prêts tandis que hollywood où on
m'appelait lada et après l'élimination
de façon il y a eu des appels au boycott
contre koh lanta l'on vous pose la
question comprenez vous les appels au
boycott dans koh lanta c'est vrai que ça
a été un truc de fou tout le monde
appelait au boycott et lors du conseil
ce malgré et malgré ce collier
d'immunité tout va pas se passer comme
prévu que lucy une autre candidat va en
effet sortir larmes secrète qu'elle a
trouvé le bracelet noir
et oui le bracelet noir chez edouard
naoum thomas un revirement de situation
qui a provoqué la colère des
téléspectateurs regardent et certains
dénonçant de la triche de la part de la
production regarder ça est ce que
quelqu'un souhaite jouer ce soir d'un
collier d'immunité
- denis
donnez ouais j'ai également une arme
secrète c'est un vrai prince édouard il
vous permet de déposséder quelqu'un en
l'occurence ce soir l'éthicien de son
collier d'immunité passant les
aventuriers de la tribu réunifiée ont
décidé de vous éliminer et leur sentence
est irrévocable initial ce sont les
destins liés et leur sentence est
irrévocable
de plus en plus étonnant oui oui oui oui
gilles verdez ou comprenez chiot que
vous avez aux petites pancartes c'est
très important ça comprenez vous l'appel
au boycott contre koh lanta ça tout le
monde en a parlé
ça fait un tout les un tollé oui et il
vers 12 totalement parce qu'on a la
preuve ultime s'il leur fallait que
c'est scénarisé
pourquoi c'est parce que pendant
l'épisode pendant l'épisode au moment du
tournage noble et les gens de la
production qui sont là bas ils ont vu
deux choses les armes secrètes ça ne
servait à rien le bracelet noir on
l'utilisait pas et vincent surclassait
tout le monde
donc ils se sont dit on va à cette
émission là en profiter tant pis on
prend le risque on sort vincent et on
truque cancale se sont dit qu'ils
allaient surclassé tout le monde que ça
n'avait plus d'intérêt et ils ont
préféré garder thomas le paul négatif
c'est bien la voir annonce alors ses
parents noté comme ça sent mauvais n'ont
ils pas d'accord se planter comme si la
dernière fois que tu es wenner des comme
ça c'est quand on t'a dit de rendre la
chèvre en fait c'est peut-être mal monté
mais c'est pas orienter ses pas
scénarisée du tocantins faut arrêter
avec cette légende de koh lanta c'est
scénarisé qu'est ce que tu veux alors
maintenant tu penses que c'est quoi non
mais je pense que ces brèves est-ce que
tu comprends qu'ils aient des gens qui
appellent ça c'est normal c'est moi moi
c'est mal monté ses rares montées à
chaque fois qu'il ya un candidat en
galère elle est là elle est comme par
hasard assise à côté du du bracelet
magique
donc je pense qu'il faut travailler là
dessus ah ouais tu vois c'est scénarisé
ouais non mais attends tu as toi
qu'est-ce que j'en veux dire faire koh
lanta laisse moi tranquille qu'est ce
que tu veux dire par là que vient de
dire je vais j'hibernais ce qu'est ce
qui va me dire s'il te plaît il vient de
dire que c'était pas scénarisée et il a
menti et j'attends de voir ce qu'ils
vont lire tous les deux parce que sakho
nîmes a écrit ce week-end
ok j'attends avec impatience un
vaudeville où sa cote alors audi alors
moi je suis entièrement d'accord avec
gilles bâillât jamais cru dire ça côté
de l'écran mais bon c'est entièrement
scénarisée et on a la preuve
parce qu'en fait si vous voulez la
production formosa va écrire je dirais
que ray manucure et de mathias poisson
comme ça c'est qu'on est au bout n'est
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
clairement clairement la production
clairement la production tient les
ficelles le seul ils peuvent vraiment
n'a influencé surtout le cours du jeu
d'accord en créant des nouvelles règles
on l'a vu il ya trois semaines d'un cran
de nouvelles règles et les écoliers sont
pas lâchés sata dégoûté parce que du
coup finalement le candide les candidats
quand ils vont finalement on n'a aucune
chance à des virements bonomo leur faire
koh lanta vietnam et la production en
fait par exemple les cogner comme dirait
agiles les colis ne sont pas cachés
avant que je commence
ils sont cachés au cours du jeu et c'est
eux en fait t'es l'armée rahman qui le
glisse enfin pendant le cours du jeu
quand ils veulent que le cas ça ça c'est
vrai c'est vrai çà mau mau mau mon
regard de moi mais tu regarde moi tenons
savoir hier que ma voix à momo el
paupières sont lourdes à face que c'est
vrai ce que tu dis ça cogne pas le les
bracelets sont ils sont ils sont
glissées çà çà çà çà çà çà c'est aussi
mais pas au début du jeu mais de là à
dire que koh lanta c'est scénarisé
je suis contre c'est scénarisé mais
alors qu'on attendait en question ça
veut dire qu'il choisisse le moment où
ils veulent le donner à quelqu'un il ne
donne pas directement le cachons rien
qu'en groupe un village programme fait
pendant que le candidat il cherche le
candidat il cherche faut savoir que
caméraman vivent avec nous faisons ils
ont ils sont près du campement et c'est
à dire en fait les candidats ils
cherchent le collier il l'introduit dans
la zone de recherche voilà et donc
forcément vous allez le trouver
denis brogniart ils m'ont dès le début
quand il dit par exemple au début de
cette aide cette aventure là il dit il
ya des armes secrètes chercher des armes
secrètes à madoff mais aucune arme
secrète cachée sur l'île au cul médecine
pas peut-être quelques unes mais qu'ils
en ont introduit en cours de jeu et puis
alors j'ai une deuxième question qui me
chamboule mais vraiment kim chamboule c
est ce qu il ya le livre de la prod ce
que j'entends le livre de la prod ses
esquives ya écrit les règles ça veut
dire est ce que le collier noir cali
enfin le bras noirs qu'éliminer collier
d'immunité est ce que c'est écrit à
l'avancé des vignals avec moi il ya un
règlement et bible avec elle et ça veut
dire qu'il ya un bras oui alors alors
vous avez beaucoup parlé ce soir gilles
verdez voit des complots partout et
servez-les island mais ils devraient
aller travailler chez julien d'accord
mais là qu'un peu candide mais n'ont
même pas du tout d'abord si on sait que
la prod et 10 ha mince vincent c'est un
excellent candidat
il fait plus chaud et oui tout le monde
va l'adorer qu'est ce qu'on va faire
pour que ça fonctionne bien sûr à
l'éliminer maintenant on va ravir juste
cynique mais il est juste extraordinaire
mais je suis super déçue de sa de son
élimination
mais pour autant et en plus on y plante
pas volé les armes secrètes parce que
vous savez à des messages dessus et avec
la pluie ça c'est face à ces voix là
également c'est vraiment la réponse avec
elisha moi je pense que la prod s'est
fait avoir dans sa supercherie
moi je pense que cette personne elle est
juste victime du jeu on a les personnes
qui sont quand même plus apte que nous à
savoir ce qui se passe dans la prod
si on nous dit que les colliers sont mis
devant la personne qui est en train de
chercher comme ça si ordonné l'arrêt de
la production
je vous le donne et moins chiant que tu
y reprendra quant à kelly avait la pêche
et que tu aurais tu veux kenya au niveau
de l'essieu à la suite de la polémique
on a contacté la production pour avoir
sa version des faits concernant une
éventuelle crise dans l'émission les
internautes ont reproché de la musique
derrière le soin de lucile avoir utilisé
son arme secrète pourrait des bacs sim
qui n'en avait pas moins pas besoin mais
selon la production
l'uci qui est très proche de maxime
s'est servi du bracelet noir
il permet de voler à collier d'immunité
à quelqu'un d'autre parce qu'elle était
très proche d'elle dans l'émission et
qu'elle craignait pour elle tout
simplement
ensuite concernant la découverte par
l'uci de ce fameux bracelet noir tu
comprends ce que tu de nombreux
internautes accusés la prod
d'abord amis cette arme secrète à ce
moment là pour que lucide le trouve
élimine vincent les petits secrets de
production
quel regard les armes secrètes sont
placés avant le début du jeu sur l'île
filmée et faire des plans de coupe pour
tout expliquer aux téléspectateurs
[Applaudissements]
ça en fait le je pense que le vin sans
senna ça dommage collatéral voilà ils
ont introduit fallait qu'ils arrêtent et
d'introduire des choses alors mais en
fait il y avait contre pourcentage de
chances que le un candidat trouve le
connais et qui trouvent et un autre
candidat trouve le collier noir ils ont
fait exprès que les deux candidats le
trouveront même ans pour sortir ça c'est
ce qu'on pense que téléspectateurs bah
oui à 47% non à 53 alors sans voix la
série série es ce que vous avez quelque
chose d'autre à ajouter
non faut pas boycotter commenta surtout
clavien sirotant mon accord écrit